andrew what is different about today's
protest i know it's a public holiday
there are more people attending has the
tone changed is it still that
festival-like atmosphere you were
describing for us yesterday
yeah on the streets i think it's still
pretty calm and relatively festive uh
one of the student leaders just was
speaking to the press a little while ago
and he seems to be trying to ratchet up
the pressure a little bit basically
saying if the chief executive loong
didn't resign by tomorrow that the
students plan to escalate the protests
previously they hadn't really said how
now they're saying they may uh surround
his official residence which would move
it closer to central again
the business district that is and also
possibly try to occupy government
buildings that would clearly set off
some kind of uh confrontation with the
police right so there's a hard deadline
in place you're saying now but
yeah but you know they said yesterday
that today was the deadline
they're not necessarily speaking with
one voice and i think you know they had
no way of knowing how big this was gonna
get and i'm not quite sure if they
really know how to get out of this
situation either as the protests have
gotten larger especially today and into
tomorrow which is another public holiday
do you see the agenda changing have the
student leaders change what they want
you know i i think their goals haven't
changed i think they're trying to figure
out how to achieve them and it's not
easy i mean the main goal is to get
beijing to back down on its plans to vet
the candidates for the the chief
executive position here when there are
elections in 2017. beijing's position is
hey we're giving you elections hong kong
has never had an election not under the
british and and not under the the post
handover period and they are offering
elections everyone can vote but they're
saying we're going to decide who the
candidates are more or less there's a
screening committee but everyone expects
that that committee would be pretty
favorable to beijing and choosing the
candidates what can you tell us about
the student leaders here because it's a
market difference from uh movements in
the past where you had the martin lee's
emily lauz leading the way here now you
have 17 year old and 18 year old
children some might say
calling the shots yeah
yeah
it's it's very interesting to see how
quickly this got out of the hands of
occupy central which was the the more
established protest group that had
planned to move into central today and
tomorrow and then basically go home and
the students have really gotten out of
front of this a lot of it had to do with
the police reaction and using the tear
gas but you know they're students
they're 17 they don't have a lot of
experience running an organization let
alone a group as big as this were where
the numbers now are topping easily
topping 100 000 possibly 150 000 last
night and who knows what it'll get to
tonight and tomorrow
it's you know these guys are young kids
and they and they're they're wrestling
and elephant now they are andrew uh
martin lee was talking to us yesterday
and telling us about how beijing had to
be behind the tear gassing of protesters
do you see any evidence that the pla or
chinese soldiers chinese authorities are
out there
no i mean i suspect they're out there
i'm sure there are planes plane coast
people observing this this is you know
something on this scale i'm sure they're
out there but no they you know since the
incident with the tear gas the police
have almost been invisible um yeah
they're there providing public safety
but really at a distance which is one of
the things i think that's ratcheted down
the tension so much is just not this
police presence let alone riot police
there you don't see any riot police at
all now uh is there evidence you know i
heard martin say that that a decision
like that couldn't be made without
beijing's knowledge it wouldn't be made
without beijing's knowledge you know
it's hard for me to say
you would think that they've been
preparing for this confrontation
everyone knew it was coming maybe not on
this scale but everyone knew that this
week the the occupy was going to happen
so the police have been preparing for it
uh if they were going to go out and use
tear gas it must have been discussed in
advance
how high those discussion went i i don't
know